imprévisible excentrique provocateur
boris johnson est un homme politique
coloris qui ne laisse personne
indifférent il n'a fait qu'une bouchée
de son rival jeremy hunt en récoltant
66% des voix des membres du parti
conservateur
né à new york en 1964 il bénéficie d'une
éducation élitiste il entame ensuite une
carrière de journaliste au times qui le
licencie pour avoir inventé une citation
maire de londres il acquiert une stature
internationale en 2016
il choisit le camp du breakbeat et
promet un royaume uni radieux préserver
d'une vague de millions d'immigrés prêt
selon lui a submergé les côtes
britanniques
le brésil voter il hérite des affaires
étrangères dans le gouvernement de
theresa may il ne tarde pas à critiquer
ses orientations sur le breakbeat et
claque finalement la porte du
gouvernement en 2018
c'était pour mieux y revenir à 55 ans
boris johnson fait le pari de réussir là
où theresa may a échoué en dénouant
l'épineux dossier du brésil de
concrétiser le break site coûte que
coûte avec ou sans accord avec l'union
européenne aie fait des bises et les new
green deal
le futur premier ministre britannique
devra gérer un autre dossier brûlant
celui de la crise diplomatique avec
l'iran
la victoire de boris johnson à la tête
du parti conservateur n'a pas tardé à
faire réagir sur la scène internationale
à commencer par le premier ministre du
canada justin trudeau qui a félicité
boris johnson en indiquant qu'il avait
hâte de travailler avec lui
le président américain donald trump a
également félicité boris johnson pour sa
victoire
[Applaudissements]
le nouveau chef du parti conservateur
britannique se présentera mercredi
devant la reine elizabeth ii qui lui
confiera la responsabilité de former le
gouvernement
il si florence guaino radio canada
montréal